welcome to this game and I'm playing
with white against jammie Dodger someone
actually wrote that I'm always giving
this name wrong yeah I admit it I always
read it as Jimmy jaundice jammy Dodger
alright so let's try Kings Indian attack
here he's played them the classical line
sometimes also called the woman
variation some named after very
well-known numb German Grand Master woof
cat woman one of the biggest um French
defense experts of all time maybe the
maybe the biggest I don't know he always
played the French ready anything else
okay this now was coming from from from
one night a 3g three but it's a he or he
always got it or not always but most of
them got it via the French okay but
let's consider this I played all the
moves to set up for a sacrifice and the
question is should I sacrifice no light
on on age six with the bishop or is this
ridiculous idea
takes Knight takes King g7 Kim G's have
none there's nothing nothing much I'm
taking with the night I don't know hmm
Bishop takes up the end it's got King h7
that's not too leading to much Bishop
takes d5 is another sacrifice that
sometimes assumed as an option yeah but
how do I play if I don't sacrifice
actually it's hard to hard to see
can play them to move like that covering
the sea bond and displaying very quickly
probably it's got some experience about
this position type yeah this is useful
maybe I need to prepare this a bit more
it's all right now this is this is now
interesting maybe Knight f6 em9 s6 the
queen is in this bishops diagonal take
stakes it's it's a yeah but no Queen
gphone how do you defend this now the
Queen c7 was very lucky move for me
otherwise I was just burnt three minutes
or two and a half minutes for nothing
now I'm burning I think at least I'm
winning yeah I can take it right or
takes h6 is better even yeah this is
good enough this is a double check okay
Quinn g7 made check me Wow but jaha who
had burned so much time yeah Quincy 7
just just just not have six center and
good for white he probably shouldn't
lose instant leave it and I don't know
with another move I'd probably I
probably played the
we played this badly and I really don't
know it's possible that i'm just clearly
worse here if I don't manage to to
sacrifice then then my see porn is just
a terrible weakness opes just a terrible
weakness and this of this runs in 2 9006
sofy if he plays let's say a form I'm
probably just bad but I don't know what
what should I play now I cannot really
sacrifice Bishop age 3 was actually
trying to improve with this the
sacrifice emk try to maybe night f7 or
something making this work but it's not
really it's not really on something like
this is just material down you only have
a couple of checks like this check and
now now it's over I cannot really suck
down and if i play move like 22 I'm
preparing that I'm not even sure if I'm
threatening it he can cover age 6 once
more and this is no problem he needs to
play Bishop f6 something like this and
this is probably good for white because
this King is weakened but it's not this
decisive thing but this is this is
winning with green g-form can do move
this but I can take here this is the
game actually
we of course not this because the Queen
hangs this is the whole whole issue yeah
bit of an unlucky unlucky move 27 I mean
you can easily think okay this is a
normal move and just do it six seconds
but this costs the game whew 22 minutes
ahead maybe invest a bit more time to to
check for the last couple of moves are
the last resorts this is just position
where white isn't swindling mode
probably no I really don't know I mean
general thing is this this plan is not
clear that this is the best you can also
play with night here and Knight to g5
trying to attack with pieces and try to
weaken them maybe this is better I don't
really know where this it's not a
regular opening that I play this is this
thing okay thanks for watching